so the Florida Department of Education
recently decided to ban AP
African-American history now AP is
relevant here that means advanced
placement these are not only elective
courses but they are above and beyond
that courses that depending on whether
you take the AP test can actually go
towards college credit and optional
elective and a very small percentage of
students take these courses and the
reason that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is now giving for the reason
that this class has been banned is
completely and totally absurd the
department says that the class was
teaching students activism
intersectionality encouraging the war
encouraging ending the war on black
Trans queer and gender non-conforming
and intersex people that it's queer
Theory and that it is indoctrination now
again this is not a mandatory class
that's being pushed on anybody it's an
elective class that students can choose
to take if this is subject matter they
are interested in and they are issues
that should be determined
from within the community not by Ron
DeSantis in terms of what is taught
DeSantis was asked about it during a
press conference and uh here is what he
had to say
that move people saying you know this is
exactly what we're appearing with the
individual Freedom bill I don't know if
you or the commissioner could maybe
expand a little bit more about sure I
mean I think so
um you know as you know in the State of
Florida our education standards not only
don't prevent but they require teaching
black history all the important things
that's part of our Core Curriculum this
was a separate course on top of that for
advanced placement credit and the issue
is we have guidance so he admits that
that's interesting we're going to get
back to that lines and standards in
Florida we want education not
indoctrination if you fall on the side
of indoctrination well we're going to
decline if it's education then we will
do this course so when I heard it didn't
meet the standards I figured yeah they
may be doing here it's way more than
that this course on black history what
are one what's one of the lessons about
okay queer Theory now who would say that
an important part of black history
queer theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards we believe in teaching
kids uh facts and how to think but we
don't believe they should have an agenda
imposed on them when you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory uh you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes so there's a
couple different things that are
important to talk about here first of
all I don't know me David pakman I don't
know whether queer first of all I don't
know whether queer theory is part of
that course but let's imagine that it is
I don't know whether it's correct
to have a part of a course about black
history include queer Theory I don't
know whether that's appropriate or not I
don't think Ron DeSantis knows either
he's not an expert on black history and
neither am I so the idea that if that is
the case that that is part of the
subject matter then the course is bad or
wrong doesn't make a lot of sense to me
that's first and foremost but again this
is an elective Associated Associated
Press AP Advance placement course okay
these are in a sense College equivalency
courses when I took AP economics for
example in high school I got college
credit for that course in college it
would be completely normal to have more
Niche classes of this style and it would
make sense that the AP black history
course would differ from whatever is
taught to every high school student but
what DeSantis and other people in
Florida are doing it's sort of slick in
a sense they want to act as though
seven-year-olds are being taught queer
theory for example or that prisons
should be abolished even if it's true
that those things are in that course
this is not being taught to first and
second graders this is an elective
College equivalency advanced placement
class but they don't want to let the
students make their own decisions
remember nobody's going to be forced
into this course students in
consultation with guidance counselors
their parents whoever can decide based
on their interests whether this is a
course that they want to take he's
removing the choice and proactively
saying we're going to get government
involved to ban a class this is part of
the decidedly anti-lgbt Bent by the way
that Ron DeSantis has been on and it's
been extra clear lately just a few days
ago DeSantis requested information from
from University Statewide of every
student who has
um I forget the exact wording but
basically it's like a list of trans
students which as we've said in other
states Texas tried this it doesn't
appear that that's actually legal so
DeSantis is making his intentions very
clear even though he claims to be small
government government shouldn't do
something unless absolutely necessary it
is not necessary to get involved in
Banning a this optional advanced
placement class and that's what he's
doing and instead of promoting education
and promoting understanding and
promoting Choice hey there's things
available to you you can choose what it
is that you want to study particularly
if you're looking at AP classes it's
instead censorship and it is ignorance
and it's all of those things so the
class should be reinstated nobody should
be forced to take it it is an optional
AP class it might have been 12 students
who were going to take this thing but
they don't care it's pathetic and it's
very clear that this is again people
like DeSantis loves to love to say the
left is virtue signaling coming out
against this class and trying to ban it
and pretending like it's being forced on
children uh is exactly the type of
virtue signaling they claim to be
against